normally in the gym our main goal is to
improve in some aspects of our physical
performance but how we go about that
improvement depends very much on
specifically what our goals are whether
we're training for size weather training
strength whether we're just training
because we really enjoy training so
there are tons of different training
principles systems and programs and each
of these will tweak the variables in
little ways whether that means changing
the number of reps the amount of weight
the frequency and in doing so hopefully
achieve different results these
different training programs also tend to
work better for different people so
that'll depend partly on your body type
and on your genetics and also just your
personal preferences for how you like to
Train several comments on this channel
have asked me to address a number of
specific training principles and
programs so in this video I'm going to
look at some of the most interesting
both from your requests and also from my
own experience and reading and address
just how different a training program
can be
so most people starting out in the gym
will either use some kind of bro split
or perhaps a full body routine maybe
some kind of circuit and they'll
gradually increase the weight in order
to see their performance and their
strength and their size improve over
time and they'll generally do this
whilst using three sets of twelve
repetitions on each exercise they might
do about five to ten different exercises
in the workout they can go home job done
but eventually gonna plateau those new
gains are gonna wear off and that's when
you're gonna need something a little bit
more advanced and a little bit more
specifically tailored to the kind of
goals that you're interested in and
that's where some of these more
interesting training principles and
systems come in and tweak some of those
variables in order to get different
results those variables can be all kinds
of things but generally we're looking at
either increasing the intensity
increasing the volume increasing the
frequency or altering the tempo so when
we say increasing intensity we mean
increasing the weight and the amount of
effort going past failure and all that
when we talk about creasing volume we're
talking about the number of repetitions
and sets in a single workout we talk
about frequency we're talking about how
much rest you have between workouts
whether you're training 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 times a week and when we
talk about tempo we're talking about how
quickly you move the weight during the
actual exercises so all of these
different variables can be tweaked to
result in different outcomes so if you
wanted to increase volume for instance
then you might try German volume
training German volume training
basically means approaching each
exercise with a 10 by 10 format so that
might mean 10 sets of benchpress and for
each set you're going to do 10
repetitions you probably start with a
weight that's around your 20 reps max
meaning that you could do 20 repetitions
with it on your first go you're gonna
stop at 10 hold some back in the tank
and then you gonna go again and go again
and go again
so German volume training is popular
with some people I believe it's what Jay
wicks recommends with his training
programs along with high-intensity
interval training for cardio and it's
what a lot of athletes and bodybuilders
have used successfully to gain strength
but right now it's not generally
considered very in vogue it's not very
popular because you're increasing the
volume yes but with those rests in
between I don't think you're gonna pull
as much blood as you could do just by
doing some kind of massive drop set as
you might do using the jy the principles
watch my video on
act for more on that and at the same
time it's still pretty intense because
if you're doing 10 times 10 at the end
of those 10 sets you're going to start
failing and start reaching failure and
having to push past and etc so you're
still fatiguing your body and the point
of increasing volume often is that is
you're going sub maximally so that
you've got more recovery time you can do
more work and then hit the gym again and
just basically increase the amount of
work you're doing on the muscle so that
you don't have to rest for long periods
and take time out with German volume
training you're kind of not getting the
best of either world you're not lifting
anything close to your one rep max so
you're not really gaining strength but
at the same time you're fatiguing your
nervous system and to me I don't think
you're gonna pull blood as much so you
could deal with some other systems so
that's one method maybe you'd like to
try it out I will say that on the whole
if you're plateauing switching to a
different training system can be a great
idea regardless of how good that
training system is because if you're
training in one modality when you switch
it's a shock to your system and you
might find that you're spun very well
and for some people increasing volume or
increasing frequency is that magic key
that they need again it depends on your
genetics I know some people respond
really well to volume and some people
respond really well to intensity I
respond really well to intensity and I
have a friend who trains with great
frequency he trains twice a day and he
balloons since he started doing that so
again that's what's so useful about
knowing your options when it comes to
how you train because it might be that
switching to a different approach is all
you need to unlock more gains one method
that I'm interested in for increasing
volume / frequency is double stimulation
training and this is something I used to
do intuitively before I realized it had
a name and it basically means that
you're training the same muscle group
two days in a row so let's say you have
quite an intense workout on your biceps
on Monday on Tuesday you normally would
avoid the biceps you probably do a
pushing exercise like triceps or you
might do your legs to give them time to
recover because they hurt but actually
did you know that training the same
muscle group two days in a row is one of
the very best ways to overcome Dom's
delayed onset muscle soreness that's the
pain you feel the next day
of course you don't want to go really
intense again because you'll cause a lot
of damage and it'll take you even longer
to recover but what you can do is to
train at the start of your workout the
same exercises did the day previous but
you're going to use lighter weights
higher rep ranges and they call this a
feeder workout and the idea is the
increasing protein synthesis your
increasing blood flow to the muscle you
are providing it with nutrients with
oxygen and you're stimulating the growth
and the recovery even faster so day one
is to make it to break it down and get
it sore and give it that stimulus to
increase in size and strength day two is
to provide it with blood to swell it up
and to increase protein synthesis to
help it grow faster and more efficiently
personally this is something that I
think makes a lot of intuitive sense
there's also a possibility it could
improve your mind muscle connection
because you can feel the muscle working
more cuz it hurts and like I say it can
actually help with recovery so that
after that workout Dom's
is gone or it's at least reduced oh and
whilst double stimulation training has
more application obviously for a
bodybuilder or someone interested in
hypertrophy or growth it could also be
useful for someone interested in
strength as a way to bring up a lagging
muscle so you don't have to use double
stimulation training on every single
muscle group you can just use it on one
particular muscle group that is lagging
behind the rest and then at the other
end of the spectrum you have protocols
designed to increase the intensity and
my commencer was one of the first people
to suggest lowering the number of reps
lowering the number of sets and
increasing the weight so that you're
getting the same amount of stimulus from
a single workout in order to trigger
that growth and then you have more rest
and you hit that muscle less but when
you do hit it you're really giving it
the impetus to grow and to get stronger
because some people will tell you that
there's a certain amount of stimulus you
need in order to stimulate growth and
once you go past that point you're kind
of wasting your time
now it's a controversial topic it's
probably true of strength than it is of
size but it's certainly again something
to mess around with and have a go with
Dorian Yates takes this to its natural
extreme with is one set strategy so the
one set strategy means that you do just
one set for each exercise so instead of
doing three times ten you just do one
times ten or 1 times 8 or 1 times 6 that
doesn't matter the point is you're going
to put all of your effort into that one
set and by do
this you're holding nothing back in the
tank you can completely exhaust yourself
for that particular movement and that
will provide a lot of stimulus without
wasting your time with lots of different
sets and reps and at the same time it
means in theory you can go past your 1
rep max because you're putting all of
your effort into a single go so you're
not saving anything in the tank so you
can try and get those PRS every single
time a slightly more mild version of
this though is reverse pyramid training
and here you're just going to put the
heaviest set right at the start of your
workout so you're still going to do
multiple sets but the first one's gonna
be the heavy one instead of building up
to it in the normal pyramid fashion you
might still have a warm-up set just for
safety just to get those joints moving
but after that you go straight into the
heaviest set so you can aim to bust your
PR when you're in a non fatigue state
and then you have something like
tri-phasic training by Cal Dietz and Ben
Peterson so here you're not mixing up
your frequency or intensity or your
volume you're mixing up instead your
tempo so that means the tempo of the
actual exercises and tri-phasic means
you going to do one phase or block of
eccentric exercises one phase or block
of isometric and one of concentric of
course all exercises are going to creat
include all three of those we're going
to emphasize on the eccentric phase the
concentric and the isometric so of
course the eccentric is the extension
the length links are going to slow that
down and really focus on it during your
first week or two weeks or three weeks
and then in the next block you're going
to focus on the middle so you might do
poor squats which means you're going to
stop and hold the weight and that
completely removes the elasticity you're
not bouncing up and then on the last
phase you're going to focus on the
concentric which is the explosive
portion so you're going to jump up out
of it or you're just going to focus more
on it and really contract the muscle as
you go through and I've talked on this
channel before about the benefits of
eccentric training for instance which
can improve your explosiveness it can
build your strength greater I've talked
about isometric training both yielding
and overcoming and I've talked about
concentric and things like starting
strength so using a tri-phasic program
like this you can focus on each aspects
of the strength and hopefully increase
things like your athletic performance
your jumping height you're running your
directional change but at the same time
coaches like it because they can use it
as a way to slow down portions of the
exercise and make sure that you're using
correct technique that you're not
cheating or bouncing your way through
that your form isn't collapsing at the
bottom or at the top and again it's just
a great new stimulus if you're used to
just performing your exercises on a
regular three one three cadence just up
and down up and down steady pace then
pausing or slowing down one part that
will greatly increase the challenge give
you something new give you some new
stimulus and that's the main takeaway
because there's loads of different
training principles out there here are
just some interesting ones that I've
described but there's many many more and
I find it's fun and interesting to try
different ones so normally if you're an
athlete or a professional you probably
pick one of these your coach would pick
one for you or they combine a few and
they create a periodized program which
would build up to your competition day
and then start again once you are back
to the start of the next season but most
of us don't train like that most of us
are just interested in being a strong
and performing as well as we can all
year round and for me personally I go to
the gym because I enjoy it so actually
I'm more interested in performance and
body weight I like to be explosive I
like to walk on my hands and things and
I'm also interested in jump height and
running speed but I train with a lot of
bro split type training a lot of drop
sets and things because that's the kind
of training I enjoy I love feeling the
stimulus which I get from intensity and
for me the big challenge is not to
increase intensity and volume to the
point where I then need to recover for
days and days or weeks and weeks because
I've over trained so the point is you
can mix and match these things in
different ways making sure to give
yourself recovery time but introducing
all these different variables mixing
them up seeing what works for you and
changing things from now and then but
also coming up with something unique to
you that involves lots of different
systems to create your own program and
your own protocol your own training
philosophy so it vans video useful
interesting guys my objective was to
show you some different options out
there and be look at some particular
training principles and systems that I
find particularly interesting and again
to answer some of the requests that I
had in the comments if there's anything
else you'd like me to tackle
then please let me know and I might do
another video like this to go over some
more different training systems in the
future
stay tuned of course if you want more
like this as well as more fitness
bodybuilding performance brain training
working online nootropics technology all
that usual stuff if that sounds good
then thanks a ton for watching and I'll
see you next time
bye for now